[Music]
he's going to hit boom that that's right
come
in bo bo that's when he
hits that's where he comes in now go
okay so that's point one it's not
that is going to be coming towards
me it's not that he's on the path until
I do the hand work both of those are
wrong he hits boom that spot right there
okay just to get the
Tilt point one point
two no don't grab don't expose this this
area here you're here you go around and
now you're on both sides of his hand
okay this is always your trap that's
your trap with your open in triangles
you push through and then you end up in
the wrist and elbow control so your
first move after you boom is to think
both right now both hands are on the
same side change hands on opposite side
don't grab anything yet push through
that that's when the Trap
closes one more time come on this
side so you have your projection popop
around both hands on comes around now
opening triangles on both sides of his
arm push through that's where you get
wrist and elbow control point
three you went from
Center to arm isolation now you have to
go back to Center so don't go here
you're just in his arm you have to make
his Center
move and that's done in the same way as
this percussion
boom that means his energy I ground
vector and move his Center
don't use hip rotation or you go into
Ura so you go
here you want to stay in
a you keep this angle to him okay let's
try okay so we'll get to
here you guys are moving
so pay attention here my hands not where
my hands are in the vertical plane
they're in the vertical plane till the
end or they moved in the sagittal plane
then I came
in you don't want that so remember this
draw
I
okay so this is why we do this basic I
know that I'm going to enter
I know that my hands are going to come
down okay and I want
them to be in this sweet spot so as I
enter my Center gets over his
elbow my hand puts his his elbow under
my Center so if I
enter then you try that that's something
different
if you come down here that's something
different we want it at the same
time there's a sweet
spot as I'm going in this is coming
under my Center gets over the elbow at
the same time his elbow gets under my
Center that's in the technique
okay so when I come around here I'm
doing the same
thing okay try it
again okay and we we have so much on
this part here where you you have that x
pattern there okay so I'm not I'm not
going to go into it because you guys
know that
but this other stuff is very important
okay so you're coming in and let's go to
the next one that I want when you when
you get the x pattern it's impossible
for him to stay on that foot you get it
that's the whole point of
it one more time that foot is the
problem that's what he's standing on so
you're going to take out you're going to
take out that basic support you can take
this line and gravity off okay but the
part I want you to
understand is make sure that when you
put this under you that where is under
where is under you or where you are over
is not leaving the line of gravity on
that foot okay so you're you're not
going
here you're you are going to ever so
slightly
attack That
Base you get it there that's the line my
line of gravity is on that Bas of
support I want his line of gravity off
of that Bas of support and I use my
hands my Tachi to do it
okay but not in Ur
I had to do everything we just did up
until now but there's an
extension
here okay got it all right okay so H how
far you do
that has to do with did I get on the
other side of his elbow okay so no I
didn't here I'm on the other side
meaning for example if if I want I can
start pushing that into the dislocation
okay but that that attack angle is what
makes the next move attack this way as
opposed to just moving the arm okay so
when you say this when you come
around there's a this way okay that we
let go for our partner But the teacher
can tell like I can tell you're not
there do you see and you come around
that way all right but when you when
you're here and you get here I can tell
oh yeah that's going that way okay and
then we just let it go for training all
right so you're going to do everything
boom off that leg but I still have that
attack angle when I come in you can see
this way boom Let It Go for him let him
move okay it's all in you can you feel
that you could press that elbow against
the shoulder and the wrist line okay
teacher knows too okay right notice that
the form changes levels
okay
so if you pay attention
I'm coming off of it do you see do you
see that I'm not I'm not here all
right so it's telling you when the move
is moving into its in Phase you have to
stay up with it
okay
so see how I stay up with it it's it's
not that
I'm shoving him down he already got
taken down I'm now on the joint okay
the reason you lose the
joint is because you were bracing on the
displacement you see so you have to wait
for that weight to get off of you then
decide it's time to enter and that's how
it gaps on your palm heel if you keep
the feeling and you're grounding
appropriately you just stay up moving
with the feeling and it never gaps okay
but he's going down because he was
falling down and I'm just aiming what's
falling do you get that it's already
fallen I'm aiming it as opposed to
taking it down or letting it rest at the
bottom both are
incorrect okay